hey guys Pete here this will be a better
call Saul season 5 episode 6 trailer
breakdown in preview the episodes
tighter Wexler V Goodman and before we
get into it I will give you a spoiler
warning this video will contain spoilers
for everything that's happened in better
call Saul and Breaking Bad before it
also gonna talk about trailers for
upcoming episodes and the titles of some
of the episodes that are out there in
the media you don't like that kind of
stuff this video won't be for you but do
subscribe to the channel on your way out
I do do episode recaps each week and
I'll be covering better call Saul
through the end of the series in season
6 as mention the title of episode six is
Wexler V Goodman there's been a lot of
discussion about that it makes it look
like we're gonna see Saul versus Kim in
the courtroom this trailer does not
actually show that though there was one
pre season trailer where we saw them in
the courtroom what we do see though is
that the film students are back we see
them in Saul's office in the back of the
nail salon the camera guy hand saw a
folder can't really see what's going on
there but I think it's funny that we see
Saul's clothes hanging up in there again
as he must have made more room for Kim
in the closet after that we see them
filming as Jimmy counts down and there's
several shots of that and there's also
an extended sneak peak that's called and
action what they're filming is anyone's
guess there's no real clues here since
we know Saul was very prolific in his
commercial making from Breaking Bad and
then when he worked with the students in
previous seasons the first thought would
be that they're making commercials for
Saul's practice this is the beginning of
his media push in the last couple of
episodes though he's been focused on
helping Kim with Mesa Verde and the mr.
Acker situation so we have to wonder if
it could be related to that there is a
cute card visible in the sneak peak
video and it does say the bank manager
couldn't but then it's cut off and we
can't see what the rest of it is so that
could be a hint that this is about the
Mesa Verde case I've seen some theories
out there about that none of them seemed
like oh yeah for sure that's gonna
happen but it's a definite possibility
Mike appears to be back in the u.s. we
see him in his car
he's doing some sort of surveillance the
episode description says Kim tries to
pump the brakes on Jimmy's latest scheme
but it may be too late to stop Saul Mike
turns up the heat on Lalo
nacho attempts to enlist support from
above this all sounds like Mike has
taken Gus up on his offer and we hear
him sitting in an office that I can't
make out where it is he says I only want
justice I assumed in on the background I
looked at the notebook I don't see any
clues that give away exactly where he's
at here based on the episode description
though it sounds like he's doing
something in relation to Lalo I
mentioned in my recap of the last
episode that I was hoping there'd be a
little bit more about him getting on
Gus's side something to tie them
together a little bit more than what we
saw I'm not sure if this is an
indication that that won't happen
it could have already happened but I am
excited either way to see Mike go up
against Lalo that's a match if I can get
behind that'll be fun to watch Gus
pulling the strings and obviously nacho
will be stuck in the middle and we do
see nacho come back in this episode
later we see Mike say I'm guessing there
something you want to get off your chest
he's standing outside of his car and
he's probably talking to nacho there
there's a quick shot of Kim walking into
her apartment that cuts to Jimmy saying
there's no way to prove anything
he has a happy look on his face he
doesn't look worried but he may be
trying to put on the best face because
something's going wrong he's saying that
to her outside the nail salon at night
and that cuts to a scene of him sitting
in his car and we see a cop car pull up
from behind and he makes a face there
that looks like he's not happy about
what's happening there's another shot of
Kim standing outside of the nail salon
looking in we see Jimmy standing in
front of their makeshift green-screen
she looks concerned this is probably
tied into her saying Kim tries to pump
the brakes on Jimmy's latest scheme we
hear Jimmy say shock and awe is what I'm
going for here as he's directing the
shoot then we get these two scantily
clad women walking into the restaurant
we've seen this restaurant several times
before the most recently when Howard and
Jimmy had lunch a couple episodes back
it seems obvious that Jimmy would be
behind this which is probably meant to
put Howard and
awkward position in front of clients or
somebody else they could be there for
Kevin as well though since it seems like
we've seen all of the lawyers meeting
here for like working lunches or
business lunches at one time or another
either way they look like working girls
and I can't imagine anybody that would
be eating here being happy about seeing
them come up to them in this public
place there's a quick shot of Kim
talking to Richard neither one of them
look excited or happy in it that cuts to
a shot of Jimmy running full speed
through the courtroom in a sharkskin
suit we see gusts getting out of an SUV
that could be at the same location where
Mike was earlier and where we'll see
nacho a little bit later the episode
description did say nacho tries to
enlist help from above if he needs help
it's probably related to his father who
smelled out him being behind the offer
from the person who offered him over the
price for his business we have to
imagine not - still trying to take care
of that I was thinking that it might be
interesting if Mike works out a deal for
nacho he does what Gus needs him to do
he becomes Gus's button man to put it in
his words but Gus has to let nacho go
because you can't really imagine any
other way for not-so to get out from
under this so I don't really have
anything to point to to say that that's
going to happen but that wouldn't make
sense in my mind after that we see Jimmy
he says hello folks as he walks into the
conference room at Schweikart and Cokely
this could be where the name Wexler V
Goodman comes from if they're meeting to
discuss the case like there may not
actually make it to the courtroom in
this episode this just could be the
origin of the case he's at the camera
one more time saying action and then the
trailer ends with a distance shot of
nacho who's standing by his car waiting
in a warehouse it's one of those classic
shots of somebody standing by a car in
the distance and it all looks like it's
connected to those earlier scenes that
we saw with Mike and possibly with Gus
as well as I mentioned there was another
sneak peek and it's just an extended
sequence of these filming scenes similar
to the 50% off one that we saw a couple
episodes back it looks like they're
having pizza
he bought everyone pizza to lure some
people in to be in their video like I
said the biggest revelation there was
the girl was holding the cue card and we
could see that it mentions a bank in it
which makes us think of Mesa Verde we
don't see a whole lot of action with Kim
here we see Kim going from point A to
point B quite a bit and looking stressed
one thing that's out there in the
universe is that there could be a teaser
for this episode of a flashback of Kim's
childhood because I am DB has somebody
listed as playing her mother the problem
with that is IMDB can be edited by
anybody and that you can't really base
anything off what you read there but I
think there's a pretty good chance that
that could happen I've been saying that
I think we need to understand what's
going on why she's doing what she's
doing because she's going down a
slippery slope she's doing things that
don't necessarily make sense for the
character we've known so hoping that
this will be the episode that worth
whatever Jimmy's doing with his filming
and how he's trying to move forward
that's gonna bring us more information
about what's going on inside of Kim's
head because really with rich in the
last episode her blowing up at the end
of the episode I mean she's gonna have
to reel things back to prove that she's
actually on Mesa Verde side or she's
gonna have to get out of the way like
she can't just keep going like that she
may still be able to pull the wool over
Kevin's eyes but it's not working with
her boss rich at her law firm so things
are gonna be coming to a head I'm
excited to see Lalo and nacho make it
back like I said I think that'll be fun
to see Mike going after Lalo for sure I
hope that it all makes sense for why he
decides to take on this life as Gus's
enforcer that we know him to be later on
and at Episode six we're past the
halfway point we're getting ready to go
into the homestretch of the season so
let me know what you're excited about
what you think's going on
what's Kim got in mind as far as what
Mesa Verde like what does she see in the
picture for Mesa Verde what's going on
there do you think it's copyright do you
think it's something else
is Jimmy making this commercial about
that something related to that a lot of
people are saying that the copyright
thing Jimmy's going to swoop in and do
something that's going to be leveraged
against Kevin like he'll have that
copyright or he'll know something about
it it's really hard to say though at
this point I hope we find out in this
next episode please like this video if
you enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already I'll be
here making videos throughout the rest
of better call Saul I hope you'll join
me thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon